servette kommt zu einem neuen video den
wir heute was ganz besonderes und
verrücktes machen und zwar werde ich
blind einkaufen und dann aus den blind
eingekauften sachen versuchen irgend
etwas essbares zuzubereiten ganz kurz
dazu da eigentlich gedanke war dass ich
im supermarkt mal rein gehe und dann wir
da die augen verbinden lasse und dann
darauf nehme aber problem dabei man
bekommt leider keine drehgenehmigung
also man darf nicht einfach so im
supermarkt film uns können die einen
rausschmeißen und herein schmeißen also
eben supermarkt selbst drehen geht
leider nicht aber das ist überhaupt kein
problem mit dem wir werden gleich die
augen verbunden und dann werde ich
online bei einem supermarkt bestellen
und am ende habe ich so einen korb an
sachen die bestimmt überhaupt nicht
zusammenpassen muss daraus irgendwas
erstmal das kochen das passiert im
heutigen video zwar mit der bestellung
magst du das gerade hinter mir wird mir
jetzt die augen verbinden leute und dann
geht es erst mal leute ich würde sagen
auf was hast du lust was mich zu kochen
eine grundzutat gewehr ich dir okay ich
will
[Musik]
nudeln nur da hätte ich auch gedacht da
kann man nicht so super viel falsch
machen die nudeln und pasta 212 artikel
ja ich würde sagen sebastian jetzt bist
du mit dem cursor in der seiten mit
das heißt kroll einfach mal rum such dir
was aus ich hab grad schon was nicht
gesehen was ich unbedingt haben will und
zwar ist es genau das hier was ich
gerade möchte das möchtest du ja du hast
dich entschieden für raich locken genuss
pur bandnudeln 500 gramm alter weste
leben bandnudeln verleiht so als
nächstes obst und gemüse gehören
eigentlich weiß erachtens nach innen
gute passiert halt richtig ja egal ob
gemüse und mach dein ding auch hier in
der kategorie habe ich nach
ausführlicher recherche was nicht
gesehen was ich haben möchte und zwar
ist es in der regel nicht schon wieder
mit dass das wollte jetzt nicht haben du
wolltest du wirklich nicht aber ich
wollte ein eisbär hat
ich wollte eigentlich dass hier bin ich
auch bin ich jetzt kann man sich
hilfsbereit
ich wollte das ja so du musst sie
entscheiden dann hat sich entschieden
für rewe die je 500 gramm alter geilnau
wobei andererseits das war nicht genug
gemüse ich es mal ein bisschen rum dass
du nicht genau weiß wo wir uns befinden
und jetzt nehmen wieder die maus sucht
irgendwie irgendwas aus dann würde ich
sagen habe ich eigentlich lust auf das
hier bin ich auch etwas drauf gerade du
bist auch was drauf okay dann möchte ich
das gerne
es wird exotisch dass die entschieden
für rewe beste wahl zucker meist
vakuumiert also zucchini und maja wollen
dass es gibt einen joker und reist am
ende hast du dein komplett voll
gestellten waren kommen dann darfst du
eine sache damit ihren okay machen
wir können ja fleisch kann machen oder
also wir dann vielleicht ist kann man
das auch daran machen was man sich
eigentlich gleichgewicht ja so ist
irgendwas raus du bist ja gut ich
sowieso bisschen rum und dann ist
relativ klar für mich dass ich das hier
haben möchte bei der postbank was ist da
nur favorisiert ja schweinefilet circa
500 gramm misst 500 gramm also das ist
echt toll was gehört dann noch rein
ich hab ne idee was tatsächlich ganz gut
sein könnte aber es musste jetzt nicht
unbedingt gefallen dort ihr seht schon
wenn du eigentlich hier machst dann wird
es teuer
er ist ja dass das war dann mitten
zwischen zeigt dann hätte ich das
sicherlich das nicht weiter links
klicken wilson jack ich hat längst okay
du hattest erst sein körper auf 109
kräuter seidling
jetzt hast du gerade ausgewählt
bio schaffen es okay ist das gut ja ich
bin schon als teenie mai
die kombination nicht so wirklich so
jetzt erste früchte die daumen das kann
jetzt alle
ja alles verändern welche kategorie sind
wir kannst du mir das sagen
saucen und bindemittel ojeda können
jetzt ganz schlimme sachen passieren
und ich will dass ganz kurzen schmerz
wie toni tomate mozzarella mal nach
mozzarella soße herzliche verhältnis ist
somit also nee aber eher zu bandnudeln
und so aber ok jetzt ist es den wagen
kommst du hast jetzt sechs artikeln drin
ich weiß nicht was dazu nicht wirklich
ein getränk immer noch wollen genau ein
köstliches getränk wird natürlich noch
wir gehen jetzt du getränke also ich
sags mal so läuten wenn man das perfekte
youtuber essen kochen möchte muss man
natürlich auch ein passendes getränke
dementsprechend fällt meine wahl heute
hier wegen der zutat die wir dem schwein
gekauft haben ganz klar dass hier das
darf ich richtig lust drauf radiowecker
es ist karottensaft da war es gar nicht
so leicht ist aber rewe bio apfelsaft
natürlich von lecker dann sehen wir dann
eine augenbinde attacke und wie hast du
deine bestellung auf einen blick die
haben schweinefilet bio apfelsaft bank
nudeln tomate und mozzarella beste wahl
zuckermais und nach im jahr aus und zog
ihn wo all diese tomatensoße mozzarella
di sieht ziemlich ekelhaft aus ich würde
glaube ich an deiner stelle den jogger
für das schweinefilet einsetzen ohne
scheiben geschickten können ohne scheiß
ja sowieso das letzte wort ich jetzt
gedacht hätte okay
denn ich wollte auf jeden fall drin das
hier muss raus ganz klar okay und dann
suche ich mir was aus der kategorie
saucen ausland ich habe schweine viele
was kann man da zu machen und bolognese
formate die das ist es das nicht so
ja wohl hier wir haben feste ganze
bolognese soße italienischen okay leute
wenn man es von dem einkaufskorb ins
geschäft gemacht und gehen damit jetzt
im supermarkt und kaufen ein
2000 leute wir haben unsere sachen wir
wie es auf der liste stand haben wir
bankenwelt wir haben apfelsaft naturtrüb
die anderen 2 zucchini
wir haben schweinefilet wieso bekommen
so kampusch am start heute und jetzt
beginnt der part wo ich nicht nur blind
bin und kochen muss mit dem was wir hier
angefangen an mit dem fleisch
das ist so krank viel älter ist mal klar
schreiben hat sie so medaillons raus
alles raus geschnitten das heißt sie
waren jetzt bisschen öl die pfanne und
braten das dann an ich bin nicht so der
absolute koch pro das heißt wenn heute
etwas essbares rauskommt aus blind
bestellt den zutaten wäre es schon für
mich relativ krass das warten beginnt
ihr schon an zu kochen ja hier haben wir
ein bisschen wasser in dem wasserkocher
heiß gemacht also einzige die wirklich
farbe ist nudeln kochen so viel leid in
die pfanne
du hast können bleibt von allen seiten
anbraten dadurch dass es so eine gewisse
keinen grund sie lachend
jetzt muss ich ein bisschen nudeln
wasser bzw
wir brauchen die 50 jahre da ist die
mitwachsen mich also julie julia als wir
manchmal so 250 gramm erreicht alles
klar jetzt zucchini war schnell gefasst
dann das scheint mir trainiert sind
kleine scheint mir nicht zu deckt weil
sonst kriegt hier den durchgegangen man
merkt dass er über das tor gehört außer
kümmert es reicht vollkommen an zucchini
wenn es bereits die zweite mensch
jetzt haben wir die 100 männer und dreht
einsatz bleibt dafür müssten aber steht
der 90 jetzt nehmen wir uns einfach so
eine handvoll an shopping aus würde ich
sagen platz einfach kurz unter wasser
ein bisschen
die nudeln sind auf jeden fall jeden
moment werden jetzt kurz schon mal an
die champignons klein zu schneiden
ich versuche mir dabei nicht komplett
alle finger abzutrennen
die musik da sagt man hat eben aus und
diesen stellen nudeln ab sagt dann das
vielleicht stadt immer ein bisschen viel
action eigentlich hier zu sehen ist
irgendwie auch die zeit die man dürfte
legen kann
zumindest scheinen weil der champignons
wir können die eigentlich gleich also
erstmal die zucchini und dann lange
warten dann nicht champignons über die
folglich kürze brauchen einfach zum
fleisch in die pfanne machen und also
ein bisschen mitgehen lassen okay was
sagst du moebel.de wachsen eben eine
sache gesagt das war der erste sinnvolle
seit wochen macht man kann das
theoretisch ein bisschen klein schneiden
einfach so zucchini turm machen und dann
einmal vierteln hielt tatsächlich sehr
gespannt mit dieser so formulieren wird
also das fleisch ist denn dann kommen
die zucchini dazu dann die soße dann am
ende noch 40 schafe aus deuten wir sie
jetzt fleisch schon richtig farbe
bekommen
ich würd sagen bahrain kinder drücken
sechseinhalb stunden später wir müssen
jetzt nur noch irgendetwas mitmachen das
ist ein bisschen seltsam lösung hat sich
das mir einfach wir machen das als
richtig rocken salate zwar nehmen uns
auch von der schlüsselbegriff ist
einfach so ein kreuz jetzt will ich
nicht was ich machen soll sondern
vorantreiben der konzern weiß einfach ab
und haben dann einfach nur um mais als
salat
das ist so ist schon gefehlt
es hat noch nie ein mensch das mit
fertigen ganz kurz kommen jetzt die
chance dazu und soße da rein wo es ist
nichts bedeutet da seht hier ist heiß
und dampfen sebastians rezept gespannt
ob sie schmecken will aber klar dass
ganz kurz noch leute ich habe es fast
vergessen
wir haben noch abgesagt ein glas mit
wasser würden und ob 3 nennen
bei dem erhöht ist von der bedeutung hat
so einige kommentare wir haben es
tatsächlich geschafft wir haben aus
einem blinden einkauf was leckeres
rausbekommen viele leute ich hab ich dir
noch eine folge was es geht verlinkt da
gibt es noch mehr videos von mir mit
unity mir zusammen und ist kostenlos
natürlich einfach wieder aufstehen
können sich am stand